[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers in
allen guten Abend eine Reihe von
spannenden und aufrüttelnden Statistiken
heute über dieses Land in dem wir leben
nach den aktuellsten Zahlen gibt es
84,4 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
das waren Ende 2022 1,3% mehr als im
Vorjahr es gibt bei uns auch mehr
Extremisten sagt der Verfassungsschutz
heute dessen Aufgabe ist laut Gesetz ist
Bestrebungen gegen die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung auszuwerten
im neuen Jahresbericht heißt es die
größte Bedrohung komme dabei von rechts
Sorgen macht die gestiegene Bereitschaft
zu Gewalt auf allen Seiten Frank
Buchwald hat die Details
fast 400 Seiten und nirgendwo Entwarnung
der Verfassungsschutzbericht enthält
nichts von politischer ermutigungsposa
die größte Bedrohung so Ministerin
Fräser kommen nach wie vor von rechts
wir dürfen die mörderische Gefahr durch
rechtsextrem muss und rechts Terrorismus
niemals unterschätzen im vergangenen
Jahr hatten die Behörden fast 21.000
rechtsextremistische Straftaten
registriert ein Plus von rund vier
Prozent die Zahl der Personen aber die
der rechtsextremen Szene zugerechnet
werden stieg um 14,5% auf 38.800
da wir die AFD mittlerweile wie sie alle
wissen als Verdachtsfall bearbeiten
haben wir erstmals einen Teil ihrer
Mitglieder auch dazu gezählt und zwar
unabhängig von der Anhängerschaft zum
ehemaligen Flügel oder der
Mitgliedschaft der im Berichtszeitraum
als Verdachtsfall bearbeiteten jungen
alternative
sogenannten reichsbürgern oder
selbstverwaltern schreiben die
Sicherheitsbehörden insgesamt
1856 Straftaten zu
zur linksextremen Szene zählt der
Verfassungsschutz 5,8% mehr Menschen als
vor einem Jahr insgesamt nun 36.500
Personen ihnen werden
3847 Straftaten zugeordnet ein leichter
Rückgang zwar aber dennoch zeigen
einzelne besonders erhebliche Angriffe
zahlreiche Körperverletzungen und die
regelmäßig verursachten hohen
Schadensummen durch Brandstiftung oder
Sachbeschädigung des unverändert Ruhe
Gefährdungspotenzial erhebliche Gefahr
für die innere Sicherheit geht nach wie
vor von islamistischem Terror aus zwei
größere Anschläge konnten im vergangenen
Jahr verhindert werden die Zahl der
Straftaten mit ausländisch ideologischem
Hintergrund dazu zählen auch Spionage
und Cyberangriffe stieg auf
1974 mehr als doppelt so viel wie 2021
vor allem nach dem russischen Angriff
auf die Ukraine zu betonen ist
allerdings dass neben Russland weiter
auch Staaten wie China der Iran die
Türkei oder Nordkorea Deutschland massiv
Geheimdienst tätig unterwegs sind
Deutschland im Fadenkreuz radikale von
rechts und links rüsten auf unruhige
Zeiten und für den Verfassungsschutz
weiterhin jede Menge Arbeit
Thomas Haldenwang ist der
Verfassungsschutz Chef und jetzt bei uns
in der Sendung genannt der Haldenwang
guten Abend der Siebers so ein Bericht
kommt ja jedes Jahr allein deshalb ist
es vielleicht auch immer so ein bisschen
Routine was hält sie denn beim aktuellen
in Atem worin sehen Sie die größte
Bedrohung also Routine darf das ganze
nie werden denn wir sehen aktuell
tatsächlich eine sehr dynamische Lage
auch schon über das gesamte Jahr 2022
wir hatten in allen extremismusbereichen
aber natürlich auch im Bereich
Spionageabwehr cyberabwehr große
Herausforderungen zu bewältigen ja und
das ist ein Trend der sich fortsetzt wir
sehen immer jünger werdende Akteure wir
sehen eine hohe gewaltaffinität in
vielen Bereichen wir sehen eine
Entwicklung von mischszenen weil eben
auch die Protagonisten nicht mehr sehr
Ideologie fest sind wir sind alles
Entwicklungen die auch zu
Radikalisierung beitragen die uns Sorgen
bereiten müssen der Extremismus nimmt zu
und das bekämpfen zu können muss man
sich natürlich auch mit den Gründen
befassen was sind denn für sie die
Gründe dafür
nun aktuell kann man für das Jahr 2022
sagen dass der Angriffskrieg Putins
gegen die Ukraine sicherlich auch eine
starke Auswirkung auf die
extremismus-bereiche hatte
Putin versucht eben auch die
verschiedenen Gruppierungen in
Deutschland anzusprechen mit seinen
narrativen mit seiner Propaganda das
gelingt teilweise recht gut und für die
Rechtsextremisten kann man sagen sie
ergreifen in Mehrheit jedenfalls Partei
für Putin und verbreiten seine narrative
weiter im Linksextremismus distanziert
man sich zwar einerseits von der
russischen Gewalt aber man sucht die
Verantwortung eben auch bei NATO bei den
USA im Imperialismus im Allgemeinen und
das führt im Bereich des
Linksextremismus eben auch zu
Gewalttaten gegen Einrichtung der
Bundeswehr oder Rüstungskonzerne also
diese Situation stachelt eben auch die
verschiedenen extremismusbereiche
zusätzlich an jetzt haben sie auf der
rechten Seite dieses Mal auch eine ganze
Reihe von Angehörigen der AFD mit
reingerechnet das ist ja die Partei die
sie als Verdachtsfall beobachten auch
wenn das juristisch noch nicht endgültig
geklärt ist ob sie das dürfen wenn Sie
die aktuellen Umfragen ansehen also die
politischen Umfragen meine ich jetzt
dann könnte ihr Verdachtsfall ja in
vielen Parlamenten künftig ein
gewichtiges Wort mitreden
das ist nach den bisherigen
Umfragewerten in der Tat aktuell nicht
auszuschließen das erfüllt mich auch mit
Sorge denn aus guten Gründen haben wir
die AFD als Verdachtsfall
eingerichtet und diese Festschreibung
ist eben auch schon durch das Kölner
Verwaltungsgericht so bestätigt wir
sehen in der AFD tatsächlich starke
Strömungen die verfassungsfeindlich
agieren und da geht es insbesondere um
Hass und Hetze gegenüber Minderheiten
aller Art Minderheiten Migranten Muslime
aber auch Menschen mit anderer sexueller
Orientierung aller sind Opfer eben der
Attacken vieler afd-protagonisten wir
sehen eben dieses
völkisch-nationalistische Staatsbürger
Verständnis Staatsbürger erster und
zweiter Klasse
all das führt uns zu dieser Einschätzung
und darüber müssen wir die Bürger
informieren auch das müssen die Bürger
wissen bei Ihrer Wahl Entscheidung aber
halt man wenn einer Partei die in ihrem
Extremismus Bericht vorkommt in
Ostdeutschland den Umfragen schon mal
knapp 30 Prozent bekäme und stärkste
Kraft würde was heißt denn das für ihren
Bericht und für dieses Land das ist ja
dann keine Rand Erscheinung mehr umso
wichtiger ist es dass wir eben über
diese Partei und und ihre Bestrebungen
eben aufklären über das was die Gefahr
dieser Partei für unsere Demokratie für
unsere freiheitliche Grundordnung
ausmacht und natürlich soll das auch die
gesellschaftlichen Kräfte mobilisieren
sich diesen Trend stärker
entgegenzustellen denn nicht allein der
Verfassungsschutz ist dafür zuständig
die Umfragewerte der AFD zu senken das
dazu haben wir keinerlei Möglichkeiten
aber wir können die Bevölkerung wach
rütteln wir können Politiker wachrütteln
und ja der Kampf für unsere Demokratie
muss in die gesamte Gesellschaft werden
Politiker wachrütteln sagen sie gerade
das ist ja interessant wie problematisch
ist es denn aus ihrer Sicht wenn die
Problemlösungskompetenz viele Bürger im
Moment weder bei der Regierung sehen
noch bei der klassischen Opposition
immerhin also informieren wir die
Bundesregierung die Bundesregierung muss
selber ihre Schlüsse aus den
Informationen ziehen die Sie von uns
bekommt aber es ist eben auch nicht nur
die Regierung aufgefordert sondern alle
gesellschaftlichen Gruppierungen die
diesen Kampf gegen den Rechtsextremismus
und für unsere Demokratie führen müssen
das ist auch nicht allein eine
Angelegenheit eben dann der Regierung
dann reden wir noch über den Einfluss
von außen ganz anderen Aspekt der auch
in den Bericht heute viel Raum einnimmt
die Spionage sie erwähnen dabei Russland
sie erwähnen aber auch sehr häufig China
sie sagen das ist die größte Bedrohung
im Bereich der Wirtschaftsspionage China
Versuche Zitat führende Akteure der
deutschen Wirtschaft zu
instrumentalisieren das ist jetzt wenn
ich das mal so Flaps ich sagen darf ein
bisschen Schlapphut sprechen vielleicht
was meinen Sie denn konkret damit ja
schlaf gut sprechen nun wir weisen eben
auf die zahlreichen Risiken hin die sich
aus der Zusammenarbeit mit China ergeben
uns ist bewusst dass natürlich eben sehr
starke wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeiten
bestehen aber gerade diese
wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeiten Bergen
dann eben auch politische Risiken china
könnte eben diese Situation auch zur
Durchsetzung politischer Ziele nutzen
das ist das worüber wir sprechen
darf das zum Beispiel Wirtschaftslenker
in Deutschland ganz konkret von China
unter Druck gesetzt werden
erpresst werden geradezu ja auch so
etwas gibt es die abhängiger bestimmte
Konzerne Firmen von China sind
desto offener sind die Ohren natürlich
auch für Kritik aus China und desto mehr
geht man vielleicht auch auf chinesische
Kritik ein und ja entspricht eben
insofern den Vorstellungen Pekings aber
ich muss noch mal darauf hinweisen wenn
es um Spionage geht und Einfluss
Aktivitäten dann war das Jahr 2022 über
das unser Bericht sich ja verhält
geprägt durch russische Aktivitäten die
ich da eindeutig aktuelle im Vordergrund
sehe sagt Thomas heidenbank der
Präsident des Bundesamtes für
Verfassungsschutz erhalten herzlichen
Dank für das Gespräch heute Abend
das Interview haben wir um 20 Uhr
aufgezeichnet später im heute schon an
update Fragen zum Thema und zur Rolle
der Politik an den amtierenden
Vorsitzenden des Bundestags
Innenausschusses ja und während der
verfassungsschutzform massiven
chinesischen spionageaktionen waren wir
haben es gerade gehört sitzt heute die
halbe Bundesregierung mit ihren
amtskolleginnen und Kollegen aus China
in Berlin zusammen sichtbares Zeichen
einer Lage die sich so beschreiben lässt
man kann nicht mehr richtig gemeinsam
man kann aber auch nicht ohne den
anderen und das gilt für beide Seiten
Thomas Reichert
das wichtigste bei dieser
Pressekonferenz passiert ganz am Ende
erst bedankt sich Chinas
Ministerpräsident lician ausführlich
anschließend führt er ein bisschen Regie
hilft Bundeskanzler Scholz den Kopfhörer
abzunehmen und zeigt die Richtung an
dann sind sie weg und genau das ist der
Punkt niemand dürfte diesmal unangenehme
Fragen stellen die Chinesen wollten das
so die deutschen gaben nach ob in Berlin
oder in Peking sonst waren Fragen
erlaubt das hier ist ein Tabubruch ich
glaube dass das ein schwerer Fehler war
das zuzulassen wenn wir in Deutschland
Pressekonferenzen machen laufen die nach
Regeln ab wie sie bei uns in der freien
Welt gelten oder der deutsche
Bundeskanzler sollte das nicht zulassen
das ist etwas was meine Sachen ist ein
schweres Versäumnis bei der Planung
dieser gesamten regierungskonsultation
gewesen ist
Regierungskonsultationen das macht
Deutschland eigentlich nur mit engen
Partnern aber ist das neue aggressivere
Schiene das noch Deutschland deutschen
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie nennt
China einen systemischen Rivalen von dem
man weniger abhängig sein will heute
aber scheint es eher in eine andere
Richtung zu gehen wir haben kein
Interesse an einer wirtschaftlichen
Abkopplung von China der Zugang zum
chinesischen Markt und faire Wettbewerbs
zu denen für deutsche und andere
ausländische Unternehmen in China
bleiben dabei weiterhin
Herausforderungen bei denen wir auf
konkrete Verbesserungen bringen im
Wirtschaftsministerium passiert danach
was zum Ritual dieser Treffen gehört
Papiere werden unterzeichnet für eine
noch engere Zusammenarbeit mit China
dafür treten an die Chefs von Siemens
von BMW
von Mercedes und von Volkswagen Konzerne
die mit ihren Investitionen Deutschlands
Abhängigkeit von China zuletzt erheblich
vergrößert haben
Chinas Ministerpräsident ist das nur
recht er warnt ausdrücklich vor dem
sogenannten die risking also der
Verringerung von Risiken vor dem was
Olaf Scholz eigentlich will
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass die
Freunde aus der deutschen Wirtschaft
China nicht als Risiko betrachten werden
und auch das sogenannte die risking
nicht unterstützen werden wir wollen
stattdessen noch eine faires und
leichteres investitionsumfeld schaffen
für die Unternehmen bei der Länder
immer wieder
Berlin erlebt an diesem Tag eine
chinesische Machtdemonstration und
vielleicht liegt es auch an der Form
dieser
Regierungskonsultationen
das bilaterale also das rein
deutsch-chinesische ist sicherlich kein
Format das langfristig zukunftsfähig ist
wenn wir in einer Welt uns befinden in
der China immer mächtiger wird und
Europa zusammenstehen muss um dagegen
ein Gegengewicht leisten zu können am
Abend landet Chinas Regierung in München
und wie ist gut gelaunt der Umgang
Deutschland für mehr Einfluss er weiß
wohin er will das hat er der
Bundesregierung schon mal voraus
wichtige Nachricht wichtige Entscheidung
heute aus Karlsruhe das heißt höchst
richterlich Details hast du Hannah im
Nachrichtenüberblick ja und zwar geht es
dabei um die Löhne von Strafgefangenen
wer inhaftiert ist und arbeitet muss
besser bezahlt werden das entschied das
Bundesverfassungsgericht Stundenlöhne
von drei Euro oder weniger sein
verfassungswidrig geklagt hatten zwei
Häftlinge aus Bayern und
Nordrhein-Westfalen das mit der 2025
sollen die Länder die entsprechenden
Gesetze überarbeiten eine Mindestlohn
gab Karlsruhe aber nicht vor in den
meisten Bundesländern herrscht für
Strafgefangene
die umweltministerinnen und Minister der
EU haben den Weg für verschärfte
Naturschutzauflagen frei gemacht der
Gesetzentwurf sieht vor dass in der EU
bis
2030% der Flächen und Meeresgebiete
renaturiert werden müssen geplant ist
unter anderem eine wiederbewässerung von
Mooren so sollen auch Wetterextreme wir
Dürren und Überschwemmungen abgeschwächt
werden das Vorhaben wird von Landwirten
deutlich kritisiert sie befürchten
Umsatzeinbußen
Deutschland und Kasachstan wollen
künftig wirtschaftlich enger
zusammenarbeiten das erklärten der
kasachische Präsident tokajew und
Bundespräsident Steinmeier der gerade zu
einem Staatsbesuch in dem
zentralasiatischen Land ist am Rande des
Treffens wurde dazu auch eine konkrete
Vereinbarung getroffen soll die
Raffinerie PCK in brandenburgischen
Schwedt jeden Monat 100.000 Tonnen Rohöl
aus Kasachstan erhalten und war bis Ende
des nächsten Jahres
Handarbeiten der Sohn von US-Präsident
Joe Biden hat sich wegen
Steuerhinterziehung und illegalem
Waffenbesitz schuldig bekannt mehrere
Jahre wurde gegen ihn ermittelt nun
erzielte er eine Vereinbarung mit dem
Justizministerium so konnte er einen
Prozess und wohl auch eine Haftstrafe
abwenden
exos-präsident Trump sprach in einer
Reaktion von einem korrupten beiden
Justizministerium der zuständige
Staatsanwalt war allerdings von Trump
selbst ernannt worden
mit einem bundesweiten Protesttag haben
zahlreiche Krankenhäuser heute auf ihre
finanzielle Lage aufmerksam gemacht und
mehr Geld von der Bundesregierung
gefordert wie hier in Berlin verlangten
die Protestierenden unter anderem einen
Inflationsausgleich und die aktuelle
Mehrkosten für die Krankenhäuser
aufzufangen ohne eine zusätzliche
Finanzspritze würden Insolvenzen drohen
bei Russlands Feldzug gegen die Ukraine
geraten auch internationale Beobachter
immer wieder gezielt unter Beschuss die
Organisation Reporter ohne Grenzen zählt
mindestens 19 verletzte mittlerweile
mindestens acht Reporterinnen und
Reporter haben ihr Leben verloren beim
berichten über diesen Krieg
frontberichterstattung ist eine
lebensgefährliche Aufgabe eine mit
gewaltigem Risiko und eine wichtige
Augen und Ohren der Welt in einer
Situation in der sonst neben den
Menschen auch die Wahrheit stirbt zwei
Wochen nach Beginn der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive schildert der bbc-kollege
Quentin Summer will jetzt seine
Eindrücke von der Frontlinie Andreas
stammen hat den Bericht zusammengefasst
der Weg zur Front er wird jeden Tag
weiter für die 68 jägerbrigade eine der
ukrainischen Einheiten die versuchen die
russische Armee zurückzuschlagen südlich
von Don jetzt kamen sie das Dorf blaue
datende befreien können nach Therm
Häuserkampf
die russischen Soldaten geflohen oder
zurückgelassen nun packen sie für den
nächsten Einsatz einen Angriff auf
russische Stellungen 3 Kilometer
entfernt
es ist verdammt wichtig dass du den
Leuten zuhörst genau zuhörst und alles
machst was sie sagen und lach mal warum
schaust Du so ernst wir sind dabei den
Krieg zu gewinnen
die Verluste seit Beginn der Offensive
sein hoch gewesen erklärt Kommandeur
Andrej wie viele Kameraden er verloren
hat er darf es nicht sagen
sie sind umzingelt von russischer
Artillerie müssen sich schnell bewegen
aus ihren Schützengräben lassen die
Spezialisten Drohnen aufsteigen bestückt
mit Granaten und Rauchbomben unter
stetigem Artilleriefeuer und einer noch
größeren Gefahren
Kampfjets bombardieren überall und alles
in der Gegend jeden Tag mehrmals
zurück in den Bunker
auch diesmal schafft es die Einheit von
Andrej den Gegner niederzukämpfen und
zumindest die meisten am Leben zu
bleiben in einem Krieg der ihm das
wichtigste genommen hat
dieser Helm gehörte meinem Sohn er ist
mir ein wenig zu klein aber so erinnere
ich mich an ihn erinnere ich mich
oder 21 Jahre alt er kämpft neben seinem
Vater am gleichen Frontabschnitt zwei
Tage vor Beginn der ukrainischen
Offensive tötet ihn eine russische
Kamikaze Drohne er wurde in einem
geschlossenen Sarg beigesetzt erzählt
André er war nicht mehr zu erkennen
nicht mal einen Monat ist das her
wollte ein Held sein für mich
und er hat es geschafft
ich wollte ihn beschützen aber er wollte
ein Held werden und er hat gewonnen
er wolle keine Rache ergänzt André aber
den Krieg gewinnen eine Siegesparade so
wenige tote Kameraden wie möglich dann
geht es weiter die russische Artillerie
im Nacken schnell weiter wie jeden Tag
heute früh meldet die Ukraine wieder
eine ganze Reihe russischer Luftangriffe
an vielen Orten im Land im Zentrum die
Region Kiew 3 Stunden lang haben die
gedauert
eingesetzt worden sein 35 Drohnen
iranischer Bauart die Drohnen bringen
seit längerem Angst Verzweiflung und Tod
in die Städte der Ukraine insgesamt
bereits tausendfach und sie werfen ein
grelles Licht auf die Iran Russland
connection die offenbar immer enger wird
Kamera mit mehr
[Musik]
Luftalarm in Kiel heute früh seit
Monaten greift Russland Ziele in der
Ukraine an mit Kamikaze Drohnen aus
iranischer Produktion Iran liefert den
großen Mengen drohen an Russland warnen
britische und US-Dienste
Iran exportiert seine Aggression über
die Region hinaus es beliefert russische
Truppen mit Drohnen die ukrainische
Zivilisten töten und die Infrastruktur
zerstören im Gegenzug liefert Russland
fortgeschritten
sie haben eine unglaubliche
Zerstörungskraft iranische Kamikaze
drohen vom Typ schorette ein
martialisches propagandavideo aus einem
Manöver der iranischen revolutionsgarten
auf bislang geheimen Routen gelangen
iranische Drohnen über das Kaspische
Meer in diese russischen Städte um dann
ukrainische Ziele anzugreifen
was die iranischen Drohnen von
selbstmordrosen attraktiv macht für
Russland ist dass sie Russland die
Möglichkeit geben die Ukraine in der
Tiefe anzugreifen momentan haben sie
eine Situation wo keine der beiden
Seiten ein wirklich Luft Überlegenheit
hat und Flugzeuge einsetzen könnte um
den Gegner in der Tiefe anzugreifen und
die iranischen Drohnen bieten da eine
Möglichkeit auch Militäranlagen
kritische Infrastruktur in der
ukrainischen Tiefe als greifen
dieses Propaganda-Video unterlegt mit
Hardrock Musik zeigt mobile
abschlussraum für Kamikaze drohen laut
US-Geheimdienste will Russland die
drohen Kooperation mit Iran ausbauen und
langfristig auch iranische Raketen
kaufen wissen Experten auf jeden Fall
hat Russland Interesse an iranischen
Raketen das auch schon Übereinkunft zu
geben und es geht natürlich auch darum
eigene drohnenproduktion aufzubauen in
Russland mit Unterstützung von Iran
will im Gegenzug alte russische
Kampfjets durch neue ersetzen und auch
Überwachungstechnik aus Moskau
die Allianz Moskau Teheran sie ist nicht
nur militärisch auch wirtschaftlich und
logistisch kooperieren beide und
langfristig wollen sie den Machtverlust
der USA in der Region ausnutzen man
versucht gleichzeitig das Vakuum das die
schwindende amerikanische macht in der
Region hinterlässt zu füllen und mit
seiner eigenen Vorstellungen auszufüllen
und was man auch immer mehr sieht das
ist das ist eine gewisse ideologische
Allianz gibt sowohl der Iran als auf der
Russland sehen sich selber als Opfer
westliche Hybride Kriegsführung im
militärischen ideologischen
Medienbereich
man hat Angst davor dass es eigene
Regime gestürzt werden soll und mit
einem liberalen Regime westlicher
Machart ersetzt werden soll und so
liefert heran weiter Kamikaze Drohnen
nach Moskau die in der Ukraine täglich
Menschen töten
so jetzt in der Sendung traditionell
noch mal Johanna
mit Sonnenenergie Strom erzeugen das ist
zentraler Bestandteil der Energiewende
und das machen immer mehr Haushalte und
Unternehmen in Deutschland laut dem
Statistischen Bundesamt waren im März
2,6 Millionen Anlagen installiert das
ist ein Plus von 16 Prozent innerhalb
eines Jahres Frank Bethmann das klingt
gut es gibt aber auch eine Schattenseite
denn gerade bei der Solarenergie ist die
Abhängigkeit von China immens ja
inzwischen ja muss man sagen dabei waren
es eins deutsche Solarfirmen die die
Branche anführten doch innerhalb von nur
gut zehn Jahren hat sich das Blatt
gewendet heute befinden sich mehr als
80% der weltweiten
Produktionskapazitäten für Solartechnik
in China die Volksrepublik dominiert den
Weltmarkt so erklärt sich das im
vergangenen Jahr 87% der nach
Deutschland importierten Solaranlagen
aus dem Reich der Mitte stammten manch
einer sagt die solarabhängigkeit von
China sei größer als die Gas
Abhängigkeit von bekannt war und das ist
deswegen so alarmierend weil im
Gegensatz zu Gas die Photovoltaik in
Deutschland zentraler Bestandteil der
Energiewende ist gibt es dann
Bestrebungen der deutschen Solarbranche
wieder zu Alltag Größe zurückzufinden
die heimischen Hersteller haben sich
zuletzt auf eine Aufholjagd begeben aber
es bleibt schwierig der Kostenvorteil
der Chinesen ist groß zudem gibt es bei
einigen Vorprodukten und Rohstoffen
praktisch keine Alternative zu China die
heimische Solarbranche fordert
Unterstützung Investitionen von 50
Milliarden Euro bräuchte es um die
Abhängigkeit von chinesischen
Lieferanten zu verringern ähnlich wie
bei Batteriezellen oder Halbleitern
müsste der Staat dem Unternehmen unter
die Arme greifen der Ruf also auch hier
nach Subventionen vielen Dank für deine
Einschätzungen
vier von 27 katholischen Bischöfen haben
gegen die Finanzierung eines
nachfolgeformats des Synodalen Wegs
gestimmt nun muss eine Alternative
Finanzierung gefunden werden damit das
katholische Reformvorhaben fortgesetzt
werden kann unter den vier Bischöfen ist
auch der Kölner Kardinal Woki als Grund
nannten sie Vorbehalte von Papst
franziskus gegenüber dem geplanten
Gremium und es gibt eine amtliche
Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes und zwar vor schweren
Gewittern mit Orkanböen heftigem
Starkregen und Hagel in Teilen von
Bayern
der ehemalige US-Außenminister Henry
Kissinger ist anlässlich seines
hundertsten geburtstags in seinem
Heimatort führt mit einem Festakt geehrt
worden Bundespräsident Steinmeier würde
ich den Friedensnobelpreisträger per
Videobotschaft als einen der
einflussreichsten Gestalter der
Weltpolitik als Sohn jüdischer Eltern
war Kissinger 1938 vor den
Nationalsozialisten in die USA geflohen
er wurde Sicherheitsberater unter
Präsident Nixon später auch
Außenminister Messenger war auch
umstritten etwa in seiner Rolle bei
Krisen und Konflikten
so und jetzt eine fast verzweifelte
Rettungsmission gesucht werden fünf
Menschen in einem Mini-U-Boot auf dem
Weg zum Wrack der Titanic das liegt in
knapp 4000 Meter Tiefe auf dem Boden des
Nordatlantik wo das U-Boot aktuell ist
niemand weiß es die Passagiere an Bord
haben rund 230.000 Euro für dieses
tiefsee-abenteuer bezahlt jetzt ist nur
zu hoffen dass sie nicht noch einen viel
höheren Preis zahlen müssen wenn er
Medaille
in ihrem Werbevideo verspricht die Firma
Ocean Gate ihren Kunden das Abenteuer
ihres Lebens einmal die Titanic in knapp
4000 Metern Tiefe mit eigenen Augen
sehen dieser exklusive Trip könnte für
fünf Menschen tödlich enden bereits am
Sonntag war der Kontakt des
Mutterschiffs Paula Prince zu Mini
U-Boot abgerissen vor gut zwei Stunden
brachte die US-Küstenwache die
Öffentlichkeit auf den neuesten Stand
wir suchen in einem sehr abgelegenen
Bereich 900 Meilen östlich von Cape Cord
und 400 Meilen südlich von Saint Jones
das erschwert den Einsatz es braucht
Zeit und viel Koordination und dann
haben wir gleich zwei Herausforderungen
eine Suche an der Oberfläche und eine
unter Wasser das macht es zu einer
extrem komplexen Operation
die Crew war auf dem Weg zum Wrack der
Titanic die 1912 auf ihrer Jungfernfahrt
gesunken war laut Angaben von Ocean Gate
reicht der Sauerstoff im Tauchboot für
rund 96 Stunden also wohl etwa bis
Donnerstag in kürzlichen Videos preisste
der Ocean Gate CEO noch an wie sicher
und einfach zu bedienen das U-Boot sei
wir steuern das Boot mit diesem Gaming
Controller er ist von Logitech
produziert aber sieht im Prinzip aus wie
ein PlayStation Controller wenn man nach
vorne will drückt man den Hebel nach
vorne wenn man zurück will zurück und
dasselbe für links und rechts
ob man diese vermeintliche Einfachheit
als beruhigend oder doch eher
beunruhigend empfindet bleibt wohl jedem
selbst überlassen die Firma äußerte sich
zum aktuellen Fall bisher nur
schriftlich unser gesamter Fokus liegt
auf dem Wohlergehen der Crew und wir
unternehmen jeden möglichen Schritt um
die fünf Crewmitglieder wieder sicher
zurückzuholen es gibt eine optimistische
Möglichkeit nämlich dass es entweder die
Verbindung zur Oberfläche verloren hat
oder es gab eine Fehlfunktion und das
U-Boot arbeitet weiter hat aber keinen
Kontakt zu Mutterschiff auf der anderen
Seite könnte es aber natürlich auch eine
Unfall gegeben haben es könnte sich im
Park der Titanic verfangen haben
und so geht die intensive Suche weiter
die Küstenwache muss sie bald finden die
fünf vermissten deren Traum vom
Abenteuer längst zum Albtraum geworden
ist
wohl tatsächlich nur hoffen auf ein
Wunder
das war unser heute journal an diesem
Dienstag und dann noch der Hinweis auf
unser heute journal abdate
mit Christopher Wehrmann von uns allen
hier auch den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hinter den Kameras ein angenehmen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter aus dem Süden
erreichte uns weiterhin sehr warme Luft
und warme Luftmassen können viel
Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen das spüren
während der kommende Nacht z.B Schauer
und Gewitter ziehen auf und verlagern
sich nach Nordosten zum Freitag beruhigt
sich das Wetter hier kommt dann kühlere
Luft ins Land schauen wir in die Nacht
und da gibt es Schauer und Gewitter die
allmählich nach Nordosten ziehen in der
ersten Nachthälfte gibt es im Südwesten
teilweise heftige Unwetter die können
durchaus größeren Hagel produzieren
Orkanböen und Starkregen die
Temperaturen gehen dabei zurück auf 21
Grad ganz im Westen und 15 Grad am
Alpenrand morgen am Vormittag gibt es im
Nordosten einzelne Schauer die ziehen
allmählich ab im Südwesten kommen neue
dazu und auch Gewitter sind schon dabei
die zum Nachmittag schon wieder Unwetter
Charakter haben können durchaus Frage
Starkregen und viel Wind und im Norden
da bleibt es erstmal trocken
Temperaturen steigen bis auf 32 Grad im
Südosten Deutschlands und 31 Grad nach
Osten hin 24 Grad Richtung Nordsee und
am Donnerstag erreicht uns ein
regelrechtes Unwetter tief und legt bei
den Unwetter noch mal eine Schippe oben
drauf also es wird noch mal heftiger
Temperaturen erreichen Werte bis 34 Grad
ja und am Freitag beruhigt sich das
Ganze von Nordwesten her mit kühlerer
Luft und damit ein schöner Abend